well I'm joined now from Cairo by rakma
Zay whose powerful message has gone
viral online rakma thank you very much
indeed for joining me we've got a a
slight delay uh in the connection
between us so I'm going to ask you uh
questions and give you time to answer
them uh rather than try and talk over
you because that isn't going to work uh
given the delay so let me just ask you
first of all you were on CNN I know
Clarissa Ward the correspondent that you
were uh very passionate towards in in my
opinion having worked at CNN she is one
of the best foreign correspondents in
the world and I felt uh absolutely has
tried to straddle uh this very tricky
line of reporting fairly and accurately
on what is a a horrendous conflict um
when you look back at yourself in that
exchange with Clarissa how do you feel
about the way that you addressed her do
you have any regret or do you feel you
could have expressed yourself
differently or do you feel it accurately
represented how you were
feeling
I'm not going to waste my time talking
about the report with Clarissa uh
because this takes away from the point
You' mentioned before there was a
deadlock in the debate there's no
deadlock in the debate there is Terror
in the debate you are unable to debate
with Israel because what's happened so
far is we're witnessing the sick
relationship between the United States
and Israel where basically uh the United
States has given uh a permission for
Israel to uh have genocide on ground and
what's happened is we're seeing uh no
one can say no to Israel the United
Nations isn't able to say no to Israel
without repercussions uh media in media
figures aren't able to say no to Israel
without uh without repercussions so what
ends up happening is that you're
basically raising a spoiled brat you're
unable to say no to that has now grown
up to be a sociopath and let me
reiterate that the relationship between
the United States and Israel is putting
the world in Jeopardy so what we're
witnessing now is a a a serious issue
where both parties need to reassess
their relationship I understand that
Biden because he's pitted his own people
against each other and wasted billions
of dollars uh giving them to Israel
instead of looking at his own homeless
his own medical uh care issue his own
student loans issue so a lot of American
people are also extremely angry and
they're also looking at unfair coverage
the reason this video has gone so viral
one it's alarming that it's gone so
viral because what should be going viral
is the footage that we are witnessing
out of Palestine out of the occupied
territories of children being massacred
it's not a war a war assumes that both
parties are on equal
footing okay I hear you uh what I would
say in response to that uh is that on
October the 7th Hamas who are the ruling
Authority in Gaza committed an act of
such heinous terrorism killing 1500
people including 260 people at the music
festival let meish let me finish what's
happened the militia Rak let let me just
ask you the question I'm really I'm I'm
no no you have to let me ask a question
I've been very polite to you and
respectful I've let you have your say
I'm going to say something now to you
and you can respond be in mind there's a
delay so this isn't exactly the easiest
debate to have well that's why I said at
the start why don't we let me ask
questions you answer them and that's the
way this can proceed in a respectable
manner I would simply say to you that
I've had a number of pro Palestinian
voices on this program in the last two
weeks um and a number of pro-israel
voices many of the pro Palestinian
people I've had on have been been very
quick to condemn what Hamas did on
October the 7th some have
not what's your position before we get
to what you just said to me about what
Israel has done and what America is
doing and so on what is your view as
someone in Egypt about what happened
right on your border there in Gaza uh by
Hamas against
Israel it's a very fair question
but the thing is maybe I have a
privilege being so close to the Border
having many Palestinian friends uh
knowing more history uh that I
understand that once you oppress a
people and again I'm not justifying what
happened the killing of civilians on
both parts ought to be condemned but the
danger in you starting an interview
asking me to condemn Hames then pours
into Israel's blun mind def defense of
its own state which ends up killing over
5,000 Palestinians over 700 dead and
going back to the report that you were
discussing at the beginning with the CNN
reporter the issue with that is
everything is always taken out of
context and this is the issue we have
with Western media had the journalist uh
been there on ground with the volunteers
that night as for example I was she
would have listened to the bombardment
of Israeli uh bombs that start from 2:30
a.m. and do not stop she would have also
witnessed the fact that we would get an
okay from Israel's side I'm not done
from Israel's side that the supplies
would go in and then it's like they toy
with your morale so that you for Hope
from both sides is stopped the narrative
has got to change okay the idea I I for
example I don't have the pr of Israel I
don't have the money to uh to to hire
the Justin beavers of the world and and
and have them say pray for Israel and
whatnot but what I do have is the truth
and the reason this video has gone so
viral is because people felt it people
felt that let me ask a question
rakma so my question is this when Hamas
did what they did on October the 7th
they will have known absolutely
known that Israel's response would have
been this and it would have involved the
deaths of many thousands of innocent
people in Gaza as a consequence of going
after Hamas they would have known that
so my question for you again a difficult
question I appreciate this given that
you're right there in the middle of all
this but the difficult question is how
do regular Palestinian people feel that
their ruling Authority commit an act of
Terror so heinous and they must have
known how Israel would respond and they
must have known that many thousands of
innocent Palestinians would die as a
consequence of that terror attack how do
they feel about that are they
comfortable with Hamas continuing to be
the ruling Authority in Gaza or is it
actually an act of such appalling
atrocity well that hamash should no
longer be there and if if the answer is
the Palestinian people don't want them
to be there anymore then how do you get
rid of
them
unfortunately the Palestinian people
don't have the luxury of the time to
think of Hames the the the voice notes
we're receiving from our Palestinians
Palestinian brothers and sisters from
under the rubble from uh mothers who've
lost their childrens from home families
that have been eradicated the the
sentiment we're getting from the
Palestinian people is do they see us if
the United Nations that whole premise
was to avoid this kind of genocide was
created to avoid this kind of
humanitarian crisis cannot stand up to
one spoiled brat of a fascist
organization then where are we in this
world and what's sad is that it's a top-
down movement you have the United
Nations unable to speak to Israel you
also have the the the people at work who
cannot hold the Palestinian flag who get
fired on the spot I've had people who
work in New York text me and tell me
that they've been fired on the spot what
else I've had that I unfortunately I
cannot show screenshot and last thing
screenshots of emails from from
prominent news channels where anchors
where um younger people are are emailing
producers begging are emailing one
another begging why aren't we showing
the other side why aren't you showing
the other side because what's happened
is that I have to be Isel has given you
a brand book where you can so that you
can be prim and proper in front of your
own
people clear about their intent they've
been very clear since the hag you have
to let me respond now okay I'm listening
to you respectfully I am not the media
I've given more of a platform to Pro
Palestinian people including yourself
than any other show in the world so I
present the suggestion that I'm just
like everybody
else I have deliberately given large
chunks of my show each night to voices
like yours to tell the side of the
Palestinians but again I come back to
this you talk about genocide by Israel
against Palestinian people what do you
call the Hamas stated intent they've
made no secret of it it's their stated
intent to wipe Israel off the face of
the Earth to kill all Jews and that's
exactly what we saw them try to do on
October the 7th what do you call that if
it's not
genocide but you've seen that from the
other side you know it's interesting
because this point brings one to be
called and dubbed anti-semitic you know
I believe that Israel is the most
anti-Semitic entity ever we used to live
with our Jewish brothers and sisters
here in the Middle East and in Palestine
and the creation of Israel on a racist
premise differentiated because you had
you didn't have uh uh Jewish Arabs or
whatnot you just had Arabs they were
Christian they were the people of
pal they were Muslim um they were
Jewish I don't need to because the
problem is the why are we having a
debate is it not to solve or is this for
another Sensational interview is this a
sensational interview or to solve I am
here you accused Israel a ceasefire
because the world is in
danger I have Israel of genocide I am
accusing Israel of a
genocide a genocide rakma I hear you and
you're perfectly entitled to that view
although Israel would contest that
characterization of what they have been
doing but many would agree with you but
I simply say what is Hamas waging
against Israel love would contest with
evidence rather than
Terror but do you not agree with me that
what Hamas is doing is clearly do you
not agree with me that clearly what
Hamas is waging against Israel is also
genocide by your
criteria I am I am you know what's again
again this is a dangerous uh debate
because what you're trying to put me in
is once I condemn asking a question this
once I condemn these people what that
then means what is why is this dangerous
for me because what that then means is
that you can then answer me and tell me
that Israel has the unequivocal right to
defend itself which what mean which what
that means is that they eradicate a
people who end
up so why not put a stop to this now
they're not on equal footing let me
clarify Israel like every country in the
world has an absolute
Israel a to itself the question now
is let me let me finish my point look at
the evidence let how many Palestinians
have died if you're not going to let me
finish my point you're not going to hear
what I have to say Israel has a right to
defend itself but the longer this war
goes on the more that people are saying
to Israel what is proportionate how can
killing many thousands of Palestinians
innocent women and children how can that
be right if if what happened October the
7th is wrong how can this be right and
it's a very fair point to make but my
point about all of this is you want
peace I want peace the president of the
United States and queen Ru and others
saying we've got to get to a two-state
solution to do that you've got to have
leadership which can be trusted by the
other side there is no way that Israel
will ever trust any leadership involving
Hamas and I would say the same by the
way about uh the Palestinian
Nyah I don't think they trust him either
I think you need new leadership on both
sides and and that's where the conundrum
is going to be how do you get to that
place where it's no longer Hamas
controlling pal Palestinians and no
longer Benjamin Netanyahu in charge of
the Israeli
side excellent question you apply
international law you apply
international law you allow the United
Nations to do its job job when when when
the ham situation happened for example
it was supposed to be the Red Cross to
go and negotiate Israel is is stopping
all of that on top of that it's also
terrorizing the media on top of that
it's also terrorizing individuals on top
of that it has money being poured in
from the United Nation from the United
States on top of that it has the backing
of the European Union on top of that it
has the backing of Britain that started
this whole Force so what ends up
happening is who's speaking for the
Palestinian people so for a solution to
happen you need to empower the United
Nations so that Israel is not making a
mockery of the United Nations how am I
needing to reiterate this more and more
I am giving you a solution rakma you're
giving me your solution telling me H
rakma you always be ham if you occupy a
people let me just finish this point let
me just finish this point if you occupy
a people if you occupy a people if uh
women in labor are having to give birth
at checkpoints if you're having uh
people imprisoned if you're having this
merciless bombardment of Palestinians
you are going to breed Hames it starts
with the stronger
party rakma I've given you uh a long
amount of time and this is why the
jargon is dangerous okay I hear you and
I respect your right to your opinions
and I've given you the platform to air
them and I appreciate you coming on the
program thank you very much
then that's not my job my job is to try
and interview people at the center of
this you may not like that but it is but
I appreciate you coming on the program
interviews sure it wasn't Sensational it
wasn't but thank you very
much